[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في برنامج
النقاش المغربي سنتطرق فيه لثلاثه مواضيع
وهي زياره وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى
المغرب تحضيرا لزياره ماكرون لنساله عن
اهميه الزياره وهل ستؤسس لمرحله جديده في
العلاقات بين الحنيفين التقليديين بعد
اشهر من التوتر والازمه الصامته موضوعنا
الثاني سيكون حول التنافس الامريكي الصيني
وتداعيات هذا التنافس على المنطقه
المغربيه لنختتم بالمشاركه التاريخيه
لاسود الاطلس في المونديال وانعكاسات ذلك
على صوره المملكه المغربيه في العالم طبعا
لمناقشه هذه المواضيع سيكون معنا من
الرباط محمد تاج الدين الحسيني وهو استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه محمد الخامس اهلا
بك استاذ محمد تاج الدين
اهلا وسهلا وكذلك من الجزائر العاصمه محمد
في البشير وهو استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
المدرسه الوطنيه العليا للعلوم السياسيه
بالجزائر اهلا بك
لا ادري ان كان يسمعونا استاذ محمد سي
البشير على كل ارحب بك وهنا في الاستديو
سالم الابيض وهو استاذ عالم الاجتماع
السياسي ووزير سابق اهلا وسهلا بك
استاذ تاج الدين الحسيني بعد حل مساله
تاشيره هل يمكن ان تحصل الرباط على موقف
اكثر وضوح من فرنسا تجاه مساله الصحراء
هذا الشيء ينتظره الكثيرون بكل تاكيد تلك
الازمه والعابره التي سيطرت كغمامه على
العلاقات المغربيه الفرنسيه كان يجب ان
تنتهي لان هذه العلاقات لا يمكن ان تتردا
في القطيعه بكل تاكيد علاقات راسخه جذورها
في التاريخ فرنسا
في هذه المنطقه من العالم شراكه لا تقتصر
على الجوانب السياسيه او الاقتصاديه بل
تتجاوزها الى ما هو اجتماعي وثقافي وحضاري
وبالتالي زياره وزير اليوم جاءت لتاكد ان
المراه فقد حصل وان هذه العلاقات ستطور
بسريج بعد زياره الدوله التي يفترض ان
يقوم بها الرئيس الفرنسي خلال الثلاث اشهر
المقبله مع بدايه السنه المقبله
تصريحات التي ادت بها وزيره الخارج
انه هناك نوعا بريقا من في ان تتطور هذه
علاقاتي الافضل بحيث عندما تقول بان
المغرب هو شريك له دور اسمه وضعيه منفرده
بمقارنه مع اي دوله اخرى عندما تقول باننا
يجب ان نضع استراتيجيه للتعاون خلال العشر
سنوات المقبله بطريقه شفافه وواضحه عندما
تقول بان فرنسا تتفهم بقوه طموحات المغربي
المشروعه هذا يوجه الى اراده حقيقيه في
تجاوز هذه المرحله خاصه وان الطرفين لا
اعتقد انهم لا يمكن ان يستغني عن بعضهم
في المغرب
له جاليات من المواطنين يعملون في كل
الميادين وتجاوز العمل العادي الى العمل
في المختبرات ومراكز البحث والمراكز
العليا
المساله التاشيرات هل يمكن ان تحصل الرباط
على موقف اكثر وضوح همم من قبل فرنسا تجاه
مساله الصحراء
هي همم هي اقل المشاكل حد
رغم ان هذه المشاكل العويصه وليس في
المغرب فقط وانما كذلك في الجزائر وفي
تونس في تونس اذكر انه هناك يعني يتذمر
كبير من هذه المساله مساله التاشيرات
باعتبار هذا النقص وباعتبار العدد الكبير
من الذين يتقدمون للتاشيره وينفضون وحتى
معالم التاشيره التي تقدمها بها لا تق-
اعادتها لهم هناك العديد من الاحتياجات
كثيره حتى في علاقه الفرنسيه في اكثر من
مره
انا اعتقد هذا المساله التي تتعلق
بالمجاملات السياسيه بين المغرب وفرنس
هناك تعقيدات في العلاقات هذه التعقيدات
متاديه من ناحيه من الموقف من قضيه
الصحراء الغربيه نحن نعرف جميعا ان المغرب
اتخذ قرارا بانه من لا يعترف
بمغربيه الصحراء
معناها لا يمكن ان يكون صديقا للمغرب
وربما حتى العلاقات حتى
تتوتر معه ربما حتى تقطع وفي كثير من
الاحيان المغرب قطع علاقته مع الدول
الافريقيه على اساس الموقف من الصحراء
ونحن نعرف علاقه المغرب بالاتحاد الافريقي
كيف تعثرت لسنوات طويله همم بسبب الموقف
والاعتراف بالصحه الغربيه
وفرنسا همم الان همم معناها تربت علاقات
برقماتيه جدا برقم ماتيه مع الجزائر في
اطار ازمه الغاز وازمه الطاقه وازمه
البترول المتعديه من المشكله من الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتريد ان تعوض هذا
النقص اوروبيه
في جزء منها من العلاقه التي
تزوجت مؤخرا مع الجزائر ولا اعتقد ان
الجزائر تقبل به
معناها العلاقه مع فرنسا ومذهب بما تطلب
من من من من ماده طاقيه غاز او غير ذلك
اذا فرنسا ذهبت وتبنت الموقف المغربي همم
المغرب بتطالب فرنسا ان يكون موقفه على
غرار الموقف الامريكي نعرف ان امريكا في
عهد ترامب غيرت موقفها من تبني موقف
الاستفتاء او على الاقل يعني معناها ما
تصل اليه بعثت المتحده من اتفاق الى همم
تتبني فكره الصحراء المغربيه وكان مقبله
مع الكيان الصهيوني في همم بين المغرب
وهذا يعني ننتقل الى الاستاذ محمد
على هذا الطرح
مساء الخير سيدتي
الكرام
المغرب
بعيدا عن الامور التي ان تشترك فيها الدول
المغاربيه الشرعيه
كل هذه الملفات يهم فرج وتريد ان تناقشاها
همم فصام
يعني دوله دوله وليس همم مغاربي هذا اولا
ثانيا طبعا فرنسا تحاول ولا بعد بصفه خاصه
بين الجزائر والمغرب احاول ان توازن بين
حاجتها للمصالح التي تشترك فيها مع
الجزائر خاصه الان الطاقه والاستثمارات
الفرنسيه في الجزائر ثم ال- بينما مع
المغرب هناك طبعا الملف الصحراء الغربيه
تاشيرات
عن هذه الامور كلها تحاول فرنسا ان تلعب
فيها دور القوه الاستعماريه القديمه نعترف
بهذا سواء في العلاقه مع الجزائر مع
المغرب طبعا هذا الخلفيه تريد فرنسا ان
تستخدمه ها لماذا لانه فرنسا لا تريد
للجزائر ولا للمغرب تونس ان تكون مغاربيه
كما لا تريد هذه الدول ان تكون شراكه معها
يعني
روسيا او الصين المباراه او القيمه
المتوسطه مثلا تركيا او القوى الاوروبان
ايطاليا او اسبانيا
الجنوبيه في المغرب العربي علاقات معقده
جدا نرى راي همم الاستاذ محمد تاج الدين
الحسيني هل تتفق مع هذا الطرح بان التقارب
المغربي الار فرنسي سيؤثر لا ما حاله على
العلاقات الفرنسيه الجزائريه تفضل
اوافق كثيرا ما اشار اليه ضيفكم الكريم
استاذ الابيض بهذا الخصوص لو كان المغرب
العربي الكبير موحدا لاستطاعت بلدانه ان
تتخذ مواقفه مخالفه جدا ليس فقط في مواجهه
فرنسا ولكن في مواجهه كل القضايا التي قد
تطرح الازمه عن غياب وحده المغرب العربي
[موسيقى]
جديده مع المغرب ما هي ردود فعل الجزائر
استرجعت سفيرها قطعت علاقات بالنسبه
لتصدير عده مواد والتعامل البنكي اكثر من
هذا بالنسبه للمغرب قطعت انبوب الغاز الذي
يمر نحو اسبانيا الى اخر اللائحه طويله
وبالتالي اصبحت الدول المتعامله مع
الاطراف تحاول ان تكيف علاقاتها لتلبيه
حاجيات الطرفين دون الوقوع في القطيعه مع
هذا الطرف لكن انه شيله الى ان الموقف
المغربي ظله ثابتا في هذا المجال بسبب
بسيط وهو ان موقفه فيما يتعلق بقضيه وحدته
الترابيه موقف راسخ الجذور في التاريخ
المغربي يعتبر ان سكان الصحراء قرروا فعلا
اولئك الذين يتفرجوا على كاس العالم
لاحظوا بوضوح كيف ان اقليم الصحراء جميعها
من العيون
كلها تعيش بكل مين الصحراء الذين يحملون
العلامه المغربيه ويطوفون بالشوارع
ويهللون ويمارسون الغناء الى اخر ذلك من
المظاهر
متمثله في المشاركه في صناديق اقتراح اكثر
من ذلك نعم عذرا على المقاطعه السيد محمد
تاج الدين الحسيني لكن هناك من يقول بان
التقارب بين المغرب والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل ادى بشكل او باخر الى تراجع
العلاقات المغربيه الفرنسيه هل تتفق مع
هذا الترح
همم
هذا صحيح الى اجتماع لانه لدينا ان نذكر
منذ اوائل القرن 21 عندما وقع المغرب مع
الولايات المتحده اتفاقيه للتبادل الحر
كانت انذاك وزير التجاره الخارجيه قد اذنت
مثل هذه العمليه رغم ان المغرب كان اختار
منذ مده طويله الا يضع كل بيضه في سله
واحده ان ينوع علاقاته الاقتصاديه وعلى كل
المستويات ونحن نلاحظ اتفاقيه التي وقعت
مع الصين
الاستراتيجيه المعلقه مع روسيا اتفاقيه
ممثلين مع الهند توسيع العلاقه مع تركيا
المغرب نظرا للوضعيه المحرجه
اضطر الى تنويع الشركات تفادي للوقوع في
اي ورطه مع اي من هذه الاطراف وبالتالي
حتى الان على قناه المغرب جيده على
الولايات المتحده ولكنه يبحث عن ان تكون
علاقاته اجود مع فرنسا لانها صديق تقليدي
وعلينا ان نلاحظ بهذا بخصوص ان فرنسا كانت
اول الدول التي تدافع عن المغرب داخل
المجلس الامن وهي التي تعتبرت منذ البدايه
ان مشروع الحكم الذاتي هو مقترح واقعي
ومدوم مصداقيات وموقف نتبناه وكل اعضاء
مجلس الامن المغرب لا يطالبون فرنسا ان
تفعل كما فعلت الولايات المتحده هناك
شركاء اوروبيون داخل القاره داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي وجميعا يعتبرون ان المغرب متقدم
الاتحاد وبالتالي ما فعلته اسبانيا وما
فعلته المانيا كان يبشر بتطور ايجابي
المغربي يعتبر ان فرنسا من بادي او احرار
كان ينبغي ان يستخدمه مواقيت اكثر تقدما
من كل اسبانيا والمانيا نظرا لهذه الشراكه
وفي التاريخ
والازمه كانت صامته ولم يطفوا على السطح
الا قضيه التاشيرات دون ان تكون هناك
مواجهه هي مواجهه ولكن
لفرنسا المغربي كترفين نرى راي الاستاذ
سالم الابيض تعقيبك على ما قاله الاستاذ
محمد تاج الدين الحسيني وهل فعلا التقارب
بين المغرب والولايات المتحده واسرائيل
ادى بشكل او باخر الى تراجع العلاقات
المغربيه الفرنسيه
من الموضوعيه ومن حق المغرب ان تبحث على
علاقات معناها تعزز اقتصاد هو تعزز النفوذ
المغربي وفقا للاستراتيجيه المغربيه سواء
كانت مغاربيه او في افريقيا او في العالم
الثالث او في ولكن اعتقد انا
بكل لطف يعني ان همم الضريبه كانت غاليه
الضريبه كانت غاليه لان الشعب المغربي هو
شعب عربي في في في في في اغلبه حتى ثقافيه
على الاقل ثقافيه يعني همم
بسجيته وبفترته يرفض التطبيعه وما وقع بين
المغرب والولايات المتحده كان ثمن هو
التطبيع يعني بناء علاقات مع دوله الكيان
الصهيوني التي يرفضها الشعب المغربي رفضا
والعديد من المظاهرات التي وقعت في الرباط
الى يوم الناس هذا ما زالت ترفض اي علاقه
مع الكيان الصهيوني وترفض التطبيع وتتبني
على القضاريف الفلسطيني وسنتحدث ربما فيما
بعد كيف كانت القضيه الفلسطينيه والرايه
الفلسطينيه رمز حتى في كاس العالم الاخير
في في قطر يبقى هناك اشكال اخر بالنسبه
لفرنسا فرنسا تعاني من تمدد مغربي في
افريقيا هذا التمدد هو التمدد اقتصادي
وهناك الكذلك من يسمي او يطلق الدبلوماسيه
الدينيه لان المغرب فيها العديد من الطرق
الصوفيه المنتشره في افريقيا وهذه الطرق
الصوفيه تاتي حتى ياتي بعضها وهو قياداتها
مثل الطريقه للحج يعني في فيس سنويا تقام
احتفالات دينيه سنويه كبيره استطاعت ان
تستثمرها المغرب وكان منذ زمان طويلا
نزولته للمغرب كان هناك معهد الدراسات
الافريقيه وكا هناك استراتيجيه افريقيا
همم الاستراتيجيه الافريقيه للمغرب اصطدمت
حاليا
بالاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه باعتبار
المستعمرات القديمه ان المغرب
والجزائر والكثير من الدول الاخرى ونتمنى
ان يكون كذلك الامر في المستقبل في تونس
قد تخلصت نسبيا من الارتباط الاقتصادي
التقليدي من فرنسا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى ان الصين عرضت ان تكون من
يؤمن القطار السريع الجديد الذي يربط بين
الدار البيضاء وقدير وان روسيا هناك
حوارات بين اكادير
والمغرب من اجل بعث مؤسس نوويه للطاقه
الكهربائيه يعني هناك خروج على النفوذ
الاقتصاد التقليدي
الان فرنسا
ولذلك عادت فرنسا لمحاوله بناء هذه
العلاقه او ترميمها لانها في نهايه الامر
ليست فرنسا من تطلب المغرب هي اطلب وفرنسا
الان تستجيب لما تطلبه المغرب وهو
الاعتراف بمغربيه الصحراء وقضيه التاشيرات
وربما هناك ملفات اخرى سريه متعلقه
بالارهاب متعلقه بالهجره السريه وغيرها
سيقع تناولها في القمه التي ستقع بين
الملك المغربي والرئيس الفرنسي اثناء
الزياره القادمه
الاستاذ وظيفنا من الجزائر
طبعا انا اظن يعني اظن صوتي الى صوتك
في الاستوديو لكن مع ملاحظه ان فرنسا قوه
كبيره وعندما تجرنا فرنسا الى الحدث
عن مصالحنا
وبعيدا عن الملف الذي تحدث عنه ضيفكم من
المغرب
شركات المغربيه الافريقيه المناقده
يعني
التاشيرات عندما خرج السيد وزير الخارجيه
الفرنسيه
منذ ساعات كان الحديث كثيرا عن همم
تاشيره ولم يكن هناك حديث عن يعني ملفات
اخرى
تجرنا كدول كان استعمرها الى ملكيه صغيره
بعيدا عن المفاتيح نعم
الملفات الكبرى الخاصه بالامن الهجره غير
الشرح الخاصه
وبالتاليف التحفظ عن اهتمام دول المغرب
العربي
نعم وصلت الفكره
او ننتقل الى موضوعنا الثاني ما هو القمه
الافريقيه الامريكيه للنسال عن تداعيات
التنافس الامريكي الصيني على دول المنطقه
المغربيه واعود الى محمد تاج الدين
الحسيني استاذه تجدين الحسين هل استفاقت
الولايات المتحده متاخره نوعا ما للمحاق
برقب التنافس على افريقيا لا سيما الدول
المغاربيه التي هي بوابه افريقيا
الاستراتيجيه
اتفق معك الى حد بعيد امريكا الصداقه
متاخره من غفوتها اخر اجتماعي انعقد مع
افريقيا من طرف الامريكيين كان منذ سنه
2008 في عهد الرئيس اوباما
والاشكاليه التي تعيش في الولايات المتحده
في علاقتها بافريقيا هي تغير الميزان
القوه الداخلي بين كل من الحزب الديمقراطي
والجمهوري عندما جاء ترامب الى السلطه
ولم يقوم باي محاوله في هذه المجال الان
لا اتذكر لماذا
المشروع تقريبا وهو في السنه الثالثه من
قياده الحكم
في
اعتقادي وهذا شيء اعترف به ايضا نفسه قال
اننا نبحث فراغات التي تركتها الصين
وروسيا في قلبه افريقيا
وعمل يتملا الفراغات ليست في استراتيجيه
الوجيهه للقيام بفعل ما داخل هذه المنطقه
للعالم هي استراتيجيه جد متانيه وحتى
مبالغ الماليه التي ترصد لا علاقه لها بما
تفسر الصين اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
ستجد نفسها في معركه داريه مع الصين لان
الصين فعلا ركزت وجودها اولا من خلال
المشاركه في البنيات التحتيه من طرق
وقناطر وموانئ وغير ذلك كثير لدرجه انها
ادمجت افريقيا بشكل كبير فيما يسمى
ببرنامج الحزام الطريق
الحريري القديمه وليتدخل معها واليوم
الصين تبحث عن مراكز اخرى عسكريه وموانئ
تمتلكها الى اخر ذلك في الولايات المتحده
اليوم تلعب من خلال مبادره التي
في المعاملات الوسيطه الى اخر ذلك من خلال
مساعده الوكاله التنميه الامريكيه وكذلك
مبالغ التي تؤسسها الشيء الوحيد الذي جاء
في المبادره الامريكيه اليوم وهو منطقه
حره بين الولايات المتحده وافريقيا يعني
تضم اكثر من مليار من السكان في حين ان
المغرب يقوم في هذه العلاقه مع الولايات
المتحده منذ سنه 2004 ومع ذلك لم يصل الى
نتائج ظاهره كما كان ينتظر الجميع
العلاقه همم الامريكيه الافريقيه
والمقارنه مع العلاقه الصينيه ال-
الفينيقيه والصينيه العربيه همم هو انا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعاني
استعمال رغم ان عمر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليست طويل يعني 200 او 250 سنه
ولكن مع ذلك فيما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه تقريبا ورثه الامبراطوريه
التقليديه واصبحت هي اكبر قوه يعني داعمه
للكثير من الانظمه معناها المستبده واصبح
حتى تمتلك قواعد عسكريه وخاضت حروب كثيره
مات فيها يعني الاف بالمئات الالاف اذا
كان مش ملايين الناس مثل الحرب في العراق
يعني لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في العلاقات الافريقيه ان تتخلص
بسرعه هكذا همم معناها من هذا الارث وترسي
معناها قواعد علاقات قائمه على التنميه
وعلى التعاون وعلى السلام وعلى النمو وعلى
التواصل مع حمايه المجتمعات والشعوب
وتوفيعها حقها في الحياه الكريمه
الصين همم تعمل في مجال التمدد الاقتصادي
ولكنها ليس لها ارث بالمره من ناحيه
الاستعماري اذ لم نسمعي لحد الان عن قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه في افريقيا مثلا الصين
قامت به معناها القطار الرابط السكه
الحديديه الرابطه بين جيبوتي واثيوبيا لم
نسمع انه هناك قواعد عسكريه مثلا الصين
الان هي التي تقوم مع شركه الصينيه التي
تقوم ببناء العاصمه المصريه الجديده لا
نسمع لم نسمع بقواعد عسكريه او شروط
سياسيه مصاحبه لهذا التدخل الاقتصادي
العملاق في مصر عندما تدخلت مثلا في
السعوديه والقمر الصناعي السعودي الصيني
او القمر الصناعي الجزائري الى الصيني همم
لم يرتبط طريق الحزام والحرير وهو
استراتيجيه الصينيه همم معناها فيها جانب
كبير لخدمه المجتمعات الناميه والفقيره
والاندلس المجتمعاتنا من الفقيره الان
هناك هناك بلدان متقدمه في اسبانيا وفي
ايطاليا اصبحت جزء من طريق الحزام والحرير
الفارق هو ان الولايات المتحده حتى ما
تقدمه تقدمه في اغلب الاحيان في شكل
مساعده اقتصاديه كانها منها او مساعدات
عسكريه
لجيوش في العالم كانها تتبع بشكل او باخر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي المسؤوله على بقائها
هذا لم يحدث في الصين اليوم في الصين
علاقات اقتصاديه استراتيجيه مع اشياء
بسيطه
في افريقيا دوله غنيه قطر معناها اتفاق
حول الغاز المسال توليد الغاز المسال على
مدى 27 سنه تجد ان في في همم الاخير احد
الملاعب الملاعب الكبيره ما معناها
انجازات شركه صينيه من من الملاعب
التحليليه يعني لديه الكثير من المشاريع
وغير مرتبط
بمعناها شروط سياسيه او شروط عسكريه والان
نلاحظ ان هناك بعض الدول التي كانت
التقليديا ضمن الحلف الامريكي سواء في
افريقيا او في الخليج العربي او في شمال
افريقيا بدات تخرج تدريجيا ولكن عمليه
الخروج ليست سهله يعني لا يمكن لاحد ان
يقول قد تكون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
غير استراتيجتها الان في هذه القمه ولكن
ما زال معناها همم هذا الارث مصطبطا عند
الكثير من الدول هي تخشى رده فعل ربما
متحده وهذا الحلف الاطلس الكبير ومقارنه
بسيطه فقد قبل ان انهي مثلا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قد 100 مليار
دولار في الحرب مع اوكرانيا دفعت الى حد
الان 100 مليار دولار في حين ان معناها ما
قدمته في هذه القمه للدول الافريقيه على
مدتها ثلاث سنوات مقبله هو فقد 55 مليار
دولار وجزء كبير منها في شكل اعانت معناها
لا نستطيع ان نقارن بين من جد انا الصين
هناك منشات بملايين وبئات المليارات من
الدول العربيه
كل من يرغب في الانتماء الى معناها طريق
الحزام والحرير وحتى بنسبه الينا في تونس
اكثر من مره الصينيين تقدموا من اجل انجاز
مشاريع اقتصاديه ضخمه ومدن جديده مدن
جديده ومعناها تجاريه وصناعيه وخدماتيه
ولكن القرار السياسي لم يكن يتعامل
بالطريقه الملائمه
الروسي الصيني في افريقيا هل سيعرقل خطه
الولايات المتحده
من اجل حضور اكبر لها في افريقيا ومن ثم
في الدول المغربيه
التنفس كبيرا جدا بين القوى
بالنسبه الطويل
وهذا ما رايناه من خلال
الزواج
السلام
طبعا هناك خالص
سابقه وبالتالي والغرب الان
في منطقه الساحل وفي غرب افريقيا لانها
السره الاسلام
في شؤون القاره سواء امريكا
لا تتوزع فقط في ميدان يصنع التوتر
والصراعات بل في الميدان ينقلب على تلك
المسلمات القديمه الى المسلمات الجديده
السلام تحاول نحو الديمقراطيه والاقتصاد
استاذ سالم الابيض
رهينه لتعاون الامريكي فقط
والملفات الارهاب في المنطقه المغاربيه
وفي الوطن العربي بسرعه عامه في العراق
وفي سوريا وفي ليبيا
نعم هي ملفات يعني معنيه بها اكثر من
اعترف لان ليست الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من لها مصالح فقط في المغرب
العربي هناك العديد من الدول الاخرى كنا
نتحدث عن الصين يعني لها مصالح في في
المغرب العربي ومعالجه هذه المشاكل يجب ان
تكون معالجه تشاركيه لا يجب ان تكون
معالجه احاديث الجانب يعني نحن نتبادل
المعلومات مثلا في المغرب العربي دول
المغرب العربي فقط مع الاتحاد الاوروبي او
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في حين
يمكن ان تكون هناك معلومات مهمه في روسيا
في الصين في لدى دول الافريقيه دول اسيويه
دول الخليجيه يمكن الاستفاده منها دعيني
فقدته وعلق على نقطه اخرى على ربما تهملها
الولايات المتحده او تتعامل معها بتكيله
بكيلين وهي على علاقه بالعربي بسرعه خاصه
وهي التعامل مع القضيه الفلسطينيه الصين
في القمه الافريقيه في القمه الصينيه
العربيه التي انقدت في الرياض مؤخرا برغم
انها تبنت حلت دولتين في مفارقه ربما في
نفس البيانات الاعلان الختامي الذي تبنى
الحل الدولتين بالنسبه للقضيه الفلسطينيه
تبنى حل الدوله الواحده بالنسبه لقضيه
الصين واا تايوان ولكن نحن نعرف ان في في
الصين ربما ترى ان هو نوع من الاستعمار
بالنسبه لتايوان بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
الكذلك كنا نحن نعرف وهم يرون انه استعمار
يعني لارض لهم معناها من طرف يعني همم
موجود همم الغاصب هي اعترفت مثلا تقدمت
خطوات اكثر من الولايات المتحده الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كانت تبشر ما نسميه نحن
مظلمه القرن صفقه القرن وهي ان تعلن يعني
القدس عاصمه
بين الصين همم اعترف بين الاخير ان القدس
يجب ان تقول ان تكون عاصمه لفلسطين
واعترفت انه يجب ايقاف الاستيطان والغاء
المستوطنات من الضفه الغربيه واعترفت انه
يجب اعطاء عضويه كامله لمنظمه للدوله
الفلسطينيه في منظمه الامم المتحده هذا لم
تعترف به الولايات المتحده الى حد الان لم
تتقدم يعني همم بصفه اخرى الصين معناها
تضرب على الوتر الحساس بالنسبه للعرب
يعني في القمه الاخيره في الولايات
المتحده اعطت وعود بسيطه هو انا سيكون لي
افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وعضويه دائمه
في مجلس الامن يعني هذه العمليه غير كيف
وستبقى عباره على ورق لان توجد عمليه
الان الى موضوع ان الثالث وهو تداعيات
المشاركه التاريخيه لاسود الاطلس في
المونديال على صوره المملكه المغربيه في
العالم محمد تاج الدين الحسيني
هي المكاسب ال جي واستراتيجيه المحققه من
قبل المملكه من خلال المشاركه التاريخيه
لمنتخبنا في المونديال
قبل بدعه ايام في قطر في الدوحه شكل
منعطفا حقيقيا في دور الرياضه في تغيير
الاتجاهات السياسيه وفي التاثير في العالم
هذا ليس بشيء جديد نحن نعلم ان سياسه
البينج بونج بين الصين والولايات المتحده
التي اعطت في النهايه للصين وكذا الحقيقي
داخل الجسم الامن لكن بالنسبه للدوره
المغربيه في هذه الوضعيه لم يكن اشعاعه
مرتبطا فقط بالتراب المغربي والوحده
الوطنيه ولكن كذلك في الاطار المغاربي في
اطار الافريقي العربي وكذلك الاسلامي بحيث
اولئك الذين حضروا في قطر شعره في لحظه
معينه ان المغرب يمثل الجميع في مواجهه
تحديات العولمه
[موسيقى]
نسبه الاضافه في خلال السنه المقبله باكثر
من 10% على مستوى الاستثمارات واقفال
الكثير من المستثمرين على مستوى تطوير
العطاء الرياضي في مجموعه البلدان الناميه
بدون استثناء لان النتائج التي حصلتها
المغرب مع كل من بلجيكا مثلا ومثلا في
اسبانيا وكذلك بالنسبه
للبرتغال لم تكون بمحض الصدفه او بسبب
الحد ولكن كان متجدره في التكوين الحقيقي
لهؤلاء اللاعبين سواء اولئك الذين يتكونوا
في اوروبا في ملاعب دوليه كبرى او اولئك
الذين كانوا نتيجه لاكاديميه محمد السادس
لكره القدم التي اسست منذ سنه 2010 والتي
اصبحت تعطي الان نتائجها اعتقد اليوم انني
المغاربه وللعالم النامي اليوم ان يفتخر
بما حققه الفريق المغربي وهذا كما قلت له
تداعي اسمه مهمه في ما يتعلق بالسياسه
المكانه التي يمكن اي في منطقه من العالم
ان تفتخر بها المكانه ثم كذلك الرياده في
الكثير من الميادين المغرب لا يزعم ان هذا
المكتسب يهمه كطراف اساسي ولكن يعتبر انه
يهم الجميع واكبر دليل على ذلك هو ان
ملاعب كره القدم كانت تجد بصياح الجماهير
مسانده للمغرب خاصه كل بلدان العربيه بدون
استثناء وما اعجبني فعلا هو ان يحمل
الفريق الوطني العلم الفلسطيني افتخارا به
ونرى فلسطينيين يعني ربما الشعب الوحيد
الذي قدم تقريبا 10 اغاني
في تاييد الفريق الوطني
[موسيقى]
والبعض بنكون نغيب قام بتطويع ولكنه ظل
فلسطين مثل الفلسطينيين
سواء في رئاسه ملك المغربيه لجنه القدس او
في صندوق مال القدس استديو يقدم دعما
حقيقيا للفلسطينيين في الواقع ولذلكم
يعلمون جيدا ان المغرب ليس بلد الشعارات
والهتافات ولكنه بلد العمل في الواقع وهذا
هو من عكس بوضوح على موقف الفلسطينيين لكن
داخل اقاليم الصحراء كذلك انعكاسات قويه
شاهدها مراقبون الغربيون واخذوا عنها صور
وتسجيلات فيديو وتظهر كيف ان سكان الصحراء
جميعهم بدون استثناء كانوا يحملون صور
العاهل المغربي
ويهتفون
يفتخرون لما حدث نعم
نظره اخرى على حقيقه تقرير المصير ويعطيه
نظره اخرى عن التطور الذي اصبح يعرفون
المغربي
الرياضه
هو اولا اول ملاحظه هو نحن لسنا في موقع
التحليل الرياضي يعني التحليل الرياضي
لديه من المختصين الذين يستطيعون معناها
تفكيك كل شفراته ولكن من موقع التحليل
الثقافي والاوتروبولوجي والتاريخي لابد
اولا ان يقرر ان ما وقع في قطر كاس العالم
هذه النسخه هي تعتبر طفره نوعيه في مجال
كره القدم الدوليه طفر نوعيه كذلك بالنسبه
معناها للبنيه الاساسيه لان عندما وقارن
مقارنه بسيطه بين ما انفقع ال220 مليار
دولار هم 220 مليار دولار هم فيه من اجل
اعاده بناء قطر من ناحيه البنيه الاساسيه
نعم نعم
ومعناها هذه ال- ال- في حين ان لقد
تريليونات الدولارات في حروب في بلدان
معناها مجاوره وفي بلدان العربيه اخرى وفي
كذا حقق لنا هذا الانتصار اختراق كبير جدا
اختراق انتصارا المغربي او التقدم المغربي
اختراق وكذلك ما قدمته السعوديه وما قدمته
تونس وغيره اختراق ما يمكن ان نسميه
بالتوازي مع العروبه الثقافيه او الروحيه
التي معناها هي متى بلغه الناس متى الدول
العربيه ما فوق الدول العربيه الى ما يمكن
ان نسميه العروبه الرياضيه والعروبه
الرياضيه كان شعار ورايه فلسطين هي الرايه
الرئيسيه التي ارتفعت في مقابلات المغرب
وفي غير مقابله تقريبا في كل مقابلات همم
الهاتف فيها معناها فرق همم عربي همم
المغرب يعني احدث
معناها همم
فرصه بان خلافات
يعني تتعالى عنها تتعالى عنها الشعوب ولا
تعترف بها منذ مده ليست بالبعيده كانت
هناك خلافات تونس والمغرب كانت هناك
خلافات بين الجزائر والمغرب كانت هناك
خلافات الخليج فجاه اكتشف ان الشعوب لا
تعترف بهذه الخلافات وليست خلافات
على ما صنعته الفرق العربيه وخاصه المرحله
المتقدمه التي وصل اليها الفريق المغربي
باختصار اكتب مع ضيفي من الجزائر اذا
استطاع المنتخب المغربي ان يوحد العرب
خلفه وحتى ان الجزائري شجعوه بقوه كيف
يمكن استغلال هذه اللحمه المغاربيه في
الدفع قدما بالعلاقات بين الجزائر والمغرب
تفضل باختصار
للاسف انقطع الاتصال اختم ممكن مع الاستاذ
محمد
تجدين الحسيني تفضل كيف يمكن استغلال هذه
اللحمه المغاربيه في الدفع قدما بالعلاقات
بين البلدين اختم معك
قبل قليل من ان الشعوب تعالت على النزاعات
الانظمه واكدت ان رغبتها الحقيقيه هي
الوحده والانسجام والتضامن واقول نحن
عندما نحل في جميع الاحوال فنحن تعيدون عن
تحرير الرياضي لو كان لنا ان نحل رياضيا
فرجعنا الى قضايا ضربات الجزاء والى قضايا
كذا نحن نرى كيف ان الرياضه يمكن ان تتحول
كسلاح قوي لخدمه السياسه بطريقه اخرى
طريقه اكثر تعقلا اكثر مردوديه واكثر
فعاليه بالنسبه لبناء مستقبل واظن ان هذا
درس لكل انظمه في منطقتنا المغاربيه لكي
ياخذه درس ولي يفتح الحدود وليقيم
العلاقات التضامنيه بين الشعوب لان هذه هي
الرغبه الحقيقيه للشعوب وليست تنافر
والتهديدات
لكم
على هذه المشاركه في برنامج النقاش
المغاربي الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]